[موسيقى]
شتيفان موسر سالمانيجا باراشيان بصوت عال
فابيان أنا ماتي بالفعل هنا
أنا بحاجة إلى طرق للطرق
لرسو حوالي أسبوعين
قطع عارضة تقع هنا
في بعض الأحيان يكذبون هنا وهو
تمت كتابته لأول مرة بأحرف صغيرة جدًا
كان لأن علي أن أرى أين
الطرق الآن عليك أن
لذلك يمكن أن يقطع إذا كان مرتفعًا جدًا
انظر أين أقطع لذا يجب عليه
قطع إذا كان هذا هو الحال معها
أستطيع أن أرى أين سنتجنب لا
لا لا لا يأتي في واحد
مصنع الغاز الحيوي هذا كل شيء
لا يزال يتم التعامل مع كل شيء
استغلال
[موسيقى]
ابنتي معه ماسا لديها ما لديها
أيضا فوق الماء
[موسيقى]
يخرجون يمكنك أن ترى
ثم حصلنا على طريقك في
يمكنك التوقف في المنتصف إذا أردت
إذا استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً لأنه نعم
في بعض الأحيان يتم التقليل من شأنها
الكثير من المشي لأنك تفعل بدون ذلك
هذا يحدث فقط عند 1.8 أو 3.8
كيلومترات هناك أشخاص يجرون 5
كيلومترات كانت دائمًا في دوائر
Lusatia هي متاهة و
لذلك هذا كثير ثم نحن
الحيوانات قد اختبأت ثم شاهدت
التي يجب أن تذهب إلى الحيوان التالي المحتمل
يذهب ومن ثم لا تعرف أين هم
وأذهب ثم سأحضر بعض الحيوانات
هذا يعني أن المرء يخفي واحدًا عندما
واحد من خلال متاهة الذرة لا بد لي من
لعبة رموز حيوان إلى حيوان مرؤوس
من المفترض أن يكون حافزًا صغيرًا
لكن يجب أن يكون كل واحد هو العشرة
العثور على الحيوانات ثم هناك
في نهاية الطريق مكافأة صغيرة
الصين
[موسيقى]
الآن توقف أنا هنا
نحن
عند
لطيفة لطيفة
الجديد
أضاء تريتون يورك
لقد ذهبنا إلى أصغر
الزاوية الصحيحة للأطفال والعوز
جرب الآن الفكرة الكبيرة
جيد جدا هو مثير وقوي
بالتأكيد الكثير من المرح لا ليس لدي أي شيء
أعدت
نعم ، إنها حقًا ممتعة للغاية هنا
من الجنون تمامًا الحصول على
للبحث عن طرق أنا بالفعل
للأسف ليس لدي ساعة هنا حتى الآن
وجدت كل العلامات وعليها أن تجد الطريق
يرجع
[موسيقى]
نعم تتجدد كل عام لان الشعب
تذكر بالفعل لدينا
كثير من الناس يعودون و
لذلك كل عام مسار جديد إذن
هل تعرف بالفعل ما هو ملف
أكثر إثارة للاهتمام ، حسنًا ، لقد كان هذا واحدًا
الآن على سبيل المثال الآن في غضون أسبوعين
ثم لدينا نوادي إضافية ليلة واحدة
للأطفال جاء مع مصباح يدوي
تطحن في الليل ثم تفعل
نحن أيضًا ما زلنا رحلة شبحية للغاية وهناك
تشغيل نوافذك ليلا مع
الجهات الفاعلة الحقيقية مثل رايز هورا